- Samedi après-midi,
des stationnements
d'épicerie bondés.
Des files devant les portes.
Ce qu'on peut décrire
comme un bon achalandage.
Le lendemain, les stationnements
sont vides, mis à part
quelques Québécois en quête
de denrées alimentaires, mais
qui repartiront bredouilles.
- Vousié que c'était
dimanche aujourd'hui?
- Exactement! Un peu tête
en l'air, mais...
(rires)
Je suis sortie de mon auto et
j'ai vu que il y avait personne,
dont je suis partie pour
ne pas faire l'épicerie.
- C'est plate. Je sais pas
pourquont fait çont fait çont f.
Franchement, on va-tu attraper
plus ou moins la COVID?
Non. C'est ridicule,
Monsieur le premier ministre.
- Cette frustration est palpable
du côté des associations qui
représentent les commerçan
FRANCIS MAILLY, rel. gouv.,
Conseil canadien commerce détail
- C'est une mesure qui n'aide
absolument en rien ladistanciat.
C'est pas nécessairement
une mesure de santé publique.
Au contraire, plusieurs études
parlent d'étendre les heures
d'ouverture pour faciliter
la distanciation et le traffic,
comme on l'a fait pour
le Boxing Day.
- Du côté du cabinet du ministre
Dubé, on précise que la mesure
vise à aider les employeurs
aux prises avec un manque
de personnel, notamment
en raison du nombre élevé
d'absences liées à la COVID-19.
FRANÇOIS VINCENT, v-p Qc, Féd.
de l'entreprise indépendante
- C'est pas une mesure qui
répond aux besoins des PME
en matière de pénurie de main-
d'oeuvre. Ce qu'elles demandent,
c'est des baisses de taxes
sur la masses salariale, avoir
plus de candidats notammen
en augmentant l'immigration puis
en améliorant la communication
des programmes existants.
- Certains n'ont toutefois
aucun problè n'avoir accès
seulement qu'aux pharmacies,
aux stations-service, dépanneurs
et service au volant pendant
trois dimanches consécutifs.rou.
T'sais, c'était ouvert hier soir
jusqu'à 9 h, fait que les gens
peuvent s'accommoder quand même.
- C'est les efforts qu'il faut
faire pour s'en sortir,
fait que...- Dans- Dans- Dans- l
canadien du commerce de détail
lance un appel à tous
les Québécois.- Patience, comprt
civisme, et faire preuve
d'empathie auprès
des employés du détail.
- Ici Colin Côté-Paule